-Obviously, new season started.
You were someone,
which is so impressive to me,
you keep over these years --
you've kept creating
new characters, new impressions.
Are there impressions
you want to get on this year?
-I try.
I mean, yeah.
Whoever is kind of in the news.
It's been kind of quiet
in the black community lately.
[ Laughter ]
You know, like, my go-tos
haven't really been
flaring up lately.
[ Laughter ]
Like Sharpton had that
R-S-P-E-C-T thing --
P-I-C-T, I think he said.
-Yeah.
-But that was over the summer.
-But Quincy Jones --
Am I hearing --
I'm hearing
there's some rumblings
of Kenan having a Quincy --
-Well, he has
a documentary coming out,
and he's been, like,
doing some interviews
where he's making crazy
kind of statements.
-Well, he's led
the craziest life,
and he's one of the most famous
people in the last 50 years.
-He's making pretty wild
accusations about people.
-So, can you do a little Quincy
for us?
-In real life,
Quincy Jones is very --
He talks like this.
"You know that,
at the time,
we had a lot of jazz
and there was a lot of parties.
But one time,
I saw Marlon Brando
sleeping with birds."
[ Laughter ]
"And then that was --
It was a thing like that.
You know, Mickey Rourke,
dear friend of mine.
I love having -- we play
who can make the best gumbo.
That's my favorite game."
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, for the show,
I think I got to
hype it up a little bit.
-And one of my personal
favorites that's kind of new
to the rotation
is Neil deGrasse Tyson.
-Oh, the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that vest.
-The vest.
-That vest.
That guy is the best.
He's so excited about science.
-Yeah.
-He's so hyped to, like,
you know,
share that information with you.
Like, you can follow
what he's saying.
But he's just like, "You know,
gravity is a real thing."
[ Laughter ]
"The world is not flat.
This is called gravity, okay?"
[ Laughter ]
-And, hey, buddy,
this is really exciting.
I'm gonna host in two weeks.
-That's right!
-I'm gonna come back to "SNL."
-Seth's first time hosting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How --
-I can't wait.
-You think you will --
Can I count on you
to treat me with kindness?
-Oh, I'll be kind.
I just don't know if I'll write.
'Cause, you'll probably
write everything.
-No, I don't want to write.
-Take the week off.
-I don't want to write anything.
-I can take the week off.
-You write for me.
-Yeah. No, of course.
We're gonna have a great time.
-But let's do stuff together.
I'm so happy to come back,
and I'm so happy you're there.
And it's just
a delight to have you here.
I love you so much.
-I love you.